ever feel like you're stuck in a loop
just putting out fires every day but
what if you could break free and start
designing your life instead of just
reacting to it strategic thinking is the
key it's not about solving today's
problems it's about asking why do these
problems keep happening imagine playing
chess a beginner sees only the next move
but a Grandmaster sees the entire board
planning 20 moves ahead that's the
difference between tactical and
strategic thinking here's the best part
strategic thinking isn't a gift it's a
skill you can build every time you pause
before reacting every time you consider
long-term consequences you're
strengthening your strategic muscle in
this video you'll learn how to shift
from tactical to strategic thinking
design your environment to make success
automatic turn risks into opportunities
for growth build a life where you're not
just reacting you're creating ready to
stop letting life happen to you and
start designing the life you want watch
the full video now it's time to think
like a Grandmaster your future self will
thank you